you knew they were going to do it you
knew that when joe biden got covered the
anti-vaxx was going to come out of the
woodwork
the
glee about biden having coveted was
going to come out of the woodwork and
conspiracy theories were going to come
out of the woodwork and we have all of
it for you today let's start with a fox
news contributor saying that joe biden
got covered as karma for pretending to
have cancer now this is stupid for two
reasons number one biden didn't pretend
to have cancer and number two
biden already had covid
before
he made the cancer gaffe
by all
reasonable understandings of the
incubation period of covet so let's look
at this clip and then discuss i hate to
be that annoyingly optimistic guy
there's no better time in the world to
be sick than right now today right in
history because we have more opportunity
to heal from it now than we've ever had
and uh there's no better place than
probably the white house uh to be when
you get sick i mean you have all the
resources in front of you um my
experience with kova the twice the two
times i've had it uh have the first time
i had a little bit of a fever the second
time i had a cold and i think that's
what everyone has been saying over and
over again uh so i hope well not
everyone not the million people that
died but yes many many many people have
mild symptoms and that's true and pray
that that's what the president
experiences i don't want any bad health
on him i think life comes at you fast i
think when you're pretending to have
cancer one day and you've got covered
the next you might want to recalibrate
how you treat things and how you talk um
but i'm not gonna you know i don't wish
bad luck on him and i'm not gonna say
that that's reason why it's just maybe
it's a good opportunity for him to have
a reality check i get so frustrated with
these politicians that think they have
to connect themselves to every dire
thing that happens in an american's life
and i think president uh biden uh his
little statement on cancer yesterday
just has proof of that that politicians
have taken that too far so what i hope
is he recovers fast it doesn't hurt him
that well that much at all and then when
he recovers he reconsiders um you know
just how politicians work on stuff like
this because saying he had cancer the
way he did and backtracking it the way
they did that's karma man you don't want
to it's karma man he just misspoke guys
i mean this is very very stupid as a
reminder yesterday when speaking joe
biden talked about
have cancer rather than had cancer he's
not pretending to have cancer i mean to
pretend to have cancer you'd have to be
able to say
i have this type of cancer and it's a
lie he just misspoke my mother drove us
and rather than us be able to walk
and guess what
the first frost you know what was
happening
you had to put on your windshield wipers
to get literally the oil slick off the
window
that's why i had so damn many other
people i grew up have cancer
and why can't for the longest time
delaware had the highest cancer rate in
the nation all right so he just misspoke
and then the other thing that it's some
kind of karma because biden pretended to
have cancer
uh typically it's at least two days of
incubation with covid and it was
announced very early thursday morning
biden making the cancer gaffe on
wednesday afternoon
the idea that the timing even works
doesn't work these people are very very
strange and they have extraordinarily
bizarre ideas but not as bizarre as the
ones i'm going to show you next
many of us know what it's like to have
acne show up when we least want it to
you should have seen me in middle school
now i'm on camera and i really do the
best i can to keep my skin clear and for
that i go to apostrophe our sponsor on
the apostrophe website you just answer a
few questions take a couple pictures of
your skin and then you have a virtual
visit with a board certified
dermatologist who will create a
personalized treatment plan they quickly
ship you the prescription medication i
can tell you that when it comes to acne
you're better off with a dermatologist
there are all sorts of different kinds
of acne that need different types of
treatment the over-the-counter stuff was
not what worked for me
apostrophe makes it simple and quick
i've had a great experience with
apostrophe myself you get affordable
quality medical treatment from a
licensed dermatologist and prescription
meds that actually work but i can do it
all on my phone i don't have to spend
hours in a doctor's office
my audience gets 15 off your first
dermatology visit go to
com slash pacman and use the code pacman
the link is in the description